My voice might be a little overworked.
I haven't talked at all today.
Oh gosh.
Hello everybody.
I hope you guys are coming in from just watching the VOD
preview or maybe you were there.
You already watched the VOD!
The stream!
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello.
Concert was amazing!
Thank you!
Today's stream might be a little bit shorter, as you can
tell that, um...
I am not... my voice is not 100%, so...
My voice is not 100%, so...
is not 100 but um yeah congrats on our amazing concert thank
you thank you so much for the pink thank you thank you thank
you show i did my show uh oh my gosh thank you guys thank
you Thank you so much!
Great show, Minto.
Here's the $50 we would have spent on dinner.
What are you talking about?
The show...
It wasn't even on Valentine's Day.
Well, I guess everybody...
The team was up pretty late.
Packing up everything.
I was quite...
I mean, I'm already dead.
But I was quite...
Out of commission on Saturday.
I was like...
Moisture, no!
Okay, hold on.
I'm getting ahead of myself, right?
Okay, I'm in trouble.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much, for the hug!
I'm so glad you're not!
So far, watching the stream live and seeing you and the rest
of the guests and fan kill it.
Thanks for giving us such a wonderful experience.
Thank you!
I...
No!
Oh my gosh.
I can't tell you guys how much anxiety I had going.
up into the live show.
I was asked by some friends, you know, they were like, you
know, what if you have a really good time?
And which I figured I would, right?
But they were like, what if you have a really good time?
And then, you know, that makes up for all the anxiety.
And I was like, I don't know.
I could have like the bestest ever, bestest, most stupendous
time ever.
But I don't think it...
it uh qual it justifies how nervous i was because you know
with fantastic reality i i um i it was a live band right oh
my gosh dargo thank you thank you guys for all the
memberships and thank you for the super chats and everything
thank you concert was amazing i'm absolutely i was
absolutely
Mercurially, thank you!
He did really, really great.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Pressure makes diamonds, they say.
Man, you know, with Fantastic Reality, it was a live band as
well.
But it was not my show, you know?
It was not just me!
So it was really, really scary.
Diamond dogs?
Yeah.
Yeah, but I practiced a lot.
And another thing I was really nervous about is, like, with
jazz, especially, there's so many different renditions of
songs, right?
You know what I mean?
Thank me, thank you so much.
You, the guests in the live band, were amazing.
Congrats on the new Oni-san, too.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Hope you can take it easy for a little bit.
Oh, but that's okay.
That's okay, that's okay.
Uh.
What was I saying?
Um.
Oh, yeah, there's so many different versions of jazz songs.
So I was like, what if, what if, like, their version that
they've been learning and my version that I've been learning
don't exactly sync, you know what I mean?
And, um, actually, I did mention this in the second.
show but um we had like one hour to rehearse i only got to
go through the songs once so if there was anything that i
needed to remember to to there was one thing i forgot and
they talked to me after after the show on the first show and
i remembered for the second show but um yeah it
sure that was wild to learn in person yeah just just a
little bit of rehearsal practicing it was one and done the
band were they were such professionals so honestly because
of them i feel that um that is why it was really great
uh and there were a couple things that i had to learn on the
spot so i was like oh it was it was something that i've
never done before for real so it was a crazy experience
never done in my afterlife ever the whole show was excellent
band was excellent y'all did an amazing job with those
really tight interval vocal harmonies thank you
the first take but it's a whole concert no we got me we got
to practice once
yeah so that was that was like i said you know just having
not
um having not able to practice so much and everything and it
was it was pressure but i'm glad that it ended up working
really Well, we were like, thank you so much for the hug, so
much!
This was lovely, and your new original song was fire!
Great job!
Thank you!
I'm really so, so grateful that I got to do it.
I heard that the club was pretty packed.
I'm so sorry if you were there, but I'm glad that we...
got to squeeze in and squeeze in as many people as we could
uh the box being revealed from the box i was like this is
the coolest thing ever i really loved that it was like kind
of a fake out you see the two screens on the side and you're
like maybe thinking oh minto will be on one of those screens
no i'm right there in the chocolate box in the middle so
cool if you guys know gate box like the It was, it's funny
because like there's this like Kickstarter thing for some AI
program or AI anime girl that's basically an old gate box.
Or new gate box.
But the old one was basically like a Google Home or like
Siri.
But it was an anime girl.
And I felt like that.
What's in the box?
No, we'll thank you.
Congrats, Minto!
The show is amazing!
Never could go to an IRL concert in this virtual was my
first one!
I said, love you all, and how being at home it felt like we
were hanging outside the club.
Thank you so much!
And so...
Did they have gatebox with Miku?
I don't know about Miku, but there are like...
There are like home gateboxes you can have now that you can
have like...
from Steinsgate.
You could even put, like, you can even put, like, your VR
Chata avatar in there, so it's pretty cool, actually.
The only question I have after seeing your concert is Jazz
Alba when...
I...
I don't know.
Um...
I, uh...
Uh...
you know, I picked my set list I tried to make it like a mix
of you know, there was only the one Japanese song in there
with Den Setsu which, oh, I guess that wasn't in the in the
preview but if you want to hear that of course the stream is
still up if you can get it or have a watch party with some
friends or something but then of course you know, I had a
fallout songs there too and Metal Gear, of course.
I think of Metal Gear.
I think Metal Gear was like so...
You know, singing Can't Say Goodbye to Yesterday in a jazz
club with a live band.
It was so hard not to cry.
I was so happy.
It was so awesome.
I sound like...
I sound like, oh man.
Because I'm trying not to cry.
Oh, it's so awesome.
And snake eater?
Yeah, sorry, setless spoilers.
Goffle, thank you for the pair.
I love you, me.
Don't love you, Goffle.
Thank you.
You sound like a child singer.
I do?
I'll fake it until you make it, baby.
I don't know, I felt so silly in the dress.
I felt so silly in the dress.
I'm not going to lie.
I was like, Celis was perfect.
A mixture of classic jazz standards and unique picks that
felt very personal to you.
Exactly what the show needed.
Yeah, I thought a lot about what kind of songs I wanted to
sing.
Dress was perfect.
It looked great on me.
Thank you.
Oh, Jay, thank you.
but thank you guys so much thank you thank you thank you no
oh i've i've i've put a lot of thought into how i wanted it
um and then hold on where's my where is my set list where is
my oh wait no i think i got rid of it i i deleted it already
i was like oh wait no i have it here
yeah yeah like i you know originally when this idea came
about it was like kind of levee right i was like i want to
sing a bunch of levee songs and a jazz club and i only in
the end sung one levee song but i really like that one it's
like one of my favorite songs by her and i tried to do like
a a mix of lovey songs and not so lovey songs too But
there's a lot...
Why does it feel like every jazz song is one or the other?
It's either a love song or not, right?
The band killed it.
Yeah, they did.
Jeff, thank you.
It's also funny seeing my big bald head in Aloha, I for
sure.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm wrecked to know it stressed your voice more.
Oh, no.
That's not what stressed my voice.
I went to Disney yesterday.
yesterday.
I went to Disney and I was screaming on the rise.
But the theme parks always, I feel like they ruined my voice
because they're so loud and I'm having to yell the whole
time.
I went to Disney.
Yeah, I bet that's exactly why my voice is like this.
Sorry.
I wish I could be like, oh yes, it was because I was working
so hard in my at the Mike Jazz Show.
No.
And you know what?
Oh my gosh.
Jazz version of Break Stuff.
Having the jazz version of Welcome to Mint Cafe was so...
It was so great, no.
If you haven't heard it.
But also, do you guys notice the BGM?
Wait, is it...
Can you even hear it?
Is it too quiet?
my new original song I can't sing it for you right now
because one my voice is like this but two you should go
watch the VOD so that you can hear it this is the original
song my new original song yet I'll be with you
composed by He'd be no sign of a snake eater fam.
Actually, I'd been wanting to work with him for so long,
obviously.
Oh, thank you!
Love you, Mito.
You were absolutely dazzling out there.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
You know, obviously I wanted to work with him for so long.
And, uh...
Hold on, let me double check the...
So I don't get the name wrong.
Wait, one second.
Wait, wait a second.
One second.
Wait, one second.
Scarlet Moon!
Scarlet Moon represents him, right?
They do like a bunch of video game music.
And they...
reached out first!
to us they said would you like to work with us for me isn't
that crazy isn't that so crazy
oh my gosh so of course I was just like oh oh oh You know, I
was, it's, yeah, I was like, Nori Hiko!
Hibino-san!
And so I kind of came up with this vibe.
I sent like a bunch of, you know, I like that the song is
very jazzy, but kind of lo-fi at the same time.
And hopefully it's a song that you guys can vibe to once I
release it.
Once I release it, so.
um but it was really cool because it's maybe the only time
i'll ever be able to debut an original song that is first
heard by you guys with a live band so i'm really glad that
my voice held out for the concert and everything and a jolly
good show a golly good show Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed.
Thank you, Dry Princess.
Thank you!
Yeah, and...
Let's see... I'm trying to think of, you know...
The songs I picked.
For the duets as well.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Um...
I got you under my skin?
With Amiri?
I don't know, I just felt like her...
...
voice really suited it.
I just felt like she would sound, it would be a fun song to
sing with her.
So I chose that one with her.
Fly Me to the Moon.
Actually, afterwards, I was thinking I kind of made a
mistake maybe.
Even though I thought of that song because like, you know,
the moon is at night and Nimmy is you know, a tapir, she
eats her nightmares.
But then I was like, wait, I sang a song literally called A
Thousand Dreams of You.
I should have done that as my duet with Nimmy.
Nimmy said she practiced it with her vocal coach.
She sounded incredible.
She sounded so, so good.
And she has her 3D concert this Friday.
So I put out my schedule.
But I will stream and then we'll go into a Nimmy concert.
Mm-hmm.
But I honestly, even though maybe the song choice should
have been a thousand dreams of you, she sounded so cute and
fly me to the moon that It was she sounded so she just
sounded so incredible like it Killed me every time I was so
good.
She just sounded so amazing.
Every time I listen to it.
I'm like, oh my gosh She's so good
And um And then Honeymoon Undutua with Densets, which was
besides my original song, the only Japanese song in the set
list.
I really have always wanted to sing this song and I felt
like with Densets it would sound really pretty.
So I wanted to sing that one.
And then Beyond the Sea, of course.
It's Sameko Sabah.
Beyond the sea, it just makes sense, no?
And she sounded so cute.
I love Sabah's singing voice so much.
Congrats on the successful concert!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Very Sabah-coded, yes!
So I picked that one for her.
And yeah, I really, I've just, there are a bunch of songs
that I, a bunch of jazz songs that I like as well.
So I was really happy to be able to sing them all.
Yeah.
I've been hoping for a collab between you and Sabah for a
very long time.
It made me so happy to finally have that wish come true.
Thank you.
Me too.
I was, I was so, so honored that she said, yeah.
So, I hope that we can collab more in the future too.
Yes, yes, yes.
Be so fun.
Play some games or something.
If she's ever down.
Yeah.
No, thank you guys.
Thank you.
You did an amazing job.
Love the show.
Thank you.
Singing with me.
I was like a drink.
A juke for me.
It was really awesome.
Being able to sing with her.
I'm just really happy I'm just I was so You know With how
many things I was uncertain about It felt like everything
could go wrong But For the most part It went really well I
think So I'm really As well as I could do I think Well I'm
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you!
Happy to see you live was enjoying the jazz, the
rearranging, the new ori song.
It was the best Valentine's ever!
I was hoping that people weren't, wouldn't expect the new
original song.
So that was, that I was excited about.
Best first!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky.
Oh, you sang so well for more so wonderfully.
Yeah, I'm so happy for you and proud of you.
Thank you.
The live band and guests were so much better.
I'm so thankful for streams.
Yes, me too.
Love you, Minto.
You're amazing, and we're so lucky to have you as a Roshi.
Thank you.
Don't worry, you can still mess everything up.
I don't want to mess everything up.
I kept hearing about everybody.
calling him trumpet guy.
I only had a chance to talk to the to the the band.
Just a tiny bit, really.
Mostly to the bassist.
This BGM sounds familiar.
Like a really good song I heard this past weekend.
Are these backing vocals here too?
Actually, no.
That doesn't sound like a me.
It's not me It's from the I haven't recorded yet I haven't
recorded it yet Okay Jeez
Did they know about vtubers before this gig?
No!
They didn't And It was really funny Like they kept taking
photos with me before the show and uh seems like the people
at the bar were quite confused they were like they were like
is this ai and after the show like they came up and they
were like amazing job like you killed it and so did they and
then even the venue staff they were like they were asking
like you know all sorts of questions and stuff and I was
like yeah I'm just I'm just a ghost maid I asked one of the
bartender ladies and she seemed kind of into the concept
cool I honestly I don't know how the band was found to be
honest but uh but one of the bandmates he oh oh my gosh hold
on I don't want My brain, sorry, is still moish.
Uh, yes.
He...
He said that he used to play with...
Sorry.
I'm getting ahead of myself.
Can't say goodbye to yesterday from Metal Gear Solid 2.
Sung by the lovely Carla White.
Sadly, she passed away.
she but one of the bandmates said that he used to play with
her in New York and he did not know about this song that she
sung so it's kind of really awesome that that I could even I
could even show him show him that so and he knew her
personally.
So cool.
It's like the whole thing just feels so like honestly just
like such a dream come true.
And I'm really happy that it went well.
And I'm happy that it's over because I was stressed so much
about it.
I'm happy that I was able to do it.
I'm so happy.
No!
I'm not crying.
You're crying.
Sorry that I was gone.
for a couple days of.
And and I went to Disney.
Actually, originally, so it was just the one show, right?
And then I was told, I was asked, do you want to do a second
show?
And I was like, of course.
If I could, you know.
So!
Glad I got to explore Jazz Concert with you.
I heard you were there on a date.
I was gonna call you out.
I forgot.
People were telling me, they were like, oh yeah, so-and-so's
here.
I met so-and-so.
There were so many familiar names.
And people that traveled from so far.
And, and, people slow dancing in the back.
Only way to desensitize yourself is to do more shows.
I guess so, honestly.
Really proud of you, Minto, you're pretty good.
Thank you.
Yeah, I am.
I'm so heavy.
What's wrong with slow dancing in the back?
I didn't say anything was wrong with it.
That's how you interpreted it.
Stop being so negative.
Stop being such a negative, Nancy.
One of your Vaughn watchers, and I didn't get a chance to
watch.
Catch a live...
Oh, I don't get a chance to catch a live stream.
I want to say congratulations, you were amazing!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
And nothing thoughtful to contribute, so congrats on the
successful Double Jazz concert, you made it!
Thank you!
I was saying, they, you know, they said like, do you want to
see about a second show?
And I was like, yes, of course.
Originally, uh, I stayed an extra day because the second
show was originally supposed to be on valentine's day
actually like valentine's day nine and then sorry hold on my
throat is starting to hurt i had already booked my tickets
and then there was like some issues with venue and they were
like the only way to do a second show is to have it at 11 p
.m and i was like know I and it would end around 2 a.m.
I felt more bad for you guys anybody who had to go to the
second show for that late um I you know I was really
grateful obviously I just felt really bad that you were
having to stay so late everybody who had to be there um and
you know I honestly like you know I didn't really give it a
second thought at all like I I was like of course you know
of course I would do it even though that means staying up
until 4 a.m.
EST not even just staying up until 4 a.m.
EST but singing and being excitable and everything so did
you feel sleepy or did the nerves keep you up I was so
sleepy in between shows i was just kind of like it's funny
because after the first show i was like i felt so relieved i
was like i did it i did it and you know for some reason my
brain was was not comprehending that i had to do it all over
again how hard did you pass out after i was still so jet
lagged that even though i went to 3 a.m.
PST I still woke up at 7 a.m.
because I usually wake up around that same time in EST so I
woke up at 7 a.m.
PST despite everything but it's okay I I took it pretty easy
on Saturday I hung out with some friends actually I don't
really go out on like holidays and stuff so I I didn't know
people went out on Valentine's Day like you know like I just
I don't know but we went to like a gardens together to walk
around and there were so many couples
the most ever they still do it's kind of crazy it was so
many people I guess that's what happens if a holiday like
Valentine's Day is on Saturday what do you think happens on
Valentine's Day I don't know I don't know I think people I
don't know I don't know Because usually I'd be streaming
I usually would be streaming I think I don't know I guess
people go out to dinner and stuff Oh yeah Yeah and then also
with my friends We went out to dinner And I
Uh...
Yeah, it was hard to get a table.
Well, actually, I think...
We didn't end up getting the table.
Not so bad.
Pretty much dinner.
Nah.
I got your first round of dinner to two patrons.
So today, love the checky.
Thank you!
With my meerkat.
I took that picture of the meerkat.
At Animal Kingdom.
he was so cute so that's my photo every densetsu patreon
checky will include a photo taken by me
my valentines usually involve a lot of wine and cheese and
whomever i'm wooing yeah but i don't know i guess you don't
know reservations on valentines it's freaky
Thank you!
Love you so much, Amito!
You were absolutely stunning up there.
Singing was captivating.
It really made my Valentine's Day special.
Thank you!
Saturday, a bunch of folks went to Asayoru.
I wanted to go to Asayoru!
I wanted to go.
Hang out with friends on Valentine's Day as well.
Never done that before either.
It was a great time.
Thanks for putting on a kind of event they'd travel across
the country for.
yeah i think honestly you know if you get kind of hung up
about holidays like a valentine's day and things like that
you know it's totally you know it's not just you can love
it's about love in general and you can love your friends and
you can love your hobbies and you can love anything that you
like so that's you know if you spend it with those people
too that's that's a perfectly fine
yourself and discount chocolate yeah discount chocolate most
people normally watch streams at valentine's day i think
that was how wide would anyway not my stream i wasn't
streaming on valentine's day who are you watching discount
chocolate discount chocolate i didn't get any chocolate
Wait.
I didn't get any chocolate from anybody.
And I didn't get any chocolate for myself.
I think I messed up.
So fun hanging out with the other Ivoos at Asayoro.
I've never been doing Make Cafe with so much, but having my
first time being with other Ivoos.
I'm so glad.
Food items were not allowed.
I'm not talking about you from you guys.
We're not allowed to send you chocolate.
I did bring chocolate for my friends though.
Chocolate buds!
Katsu, what kind of chocolate are you getting that is worth
that much?
Thank you though.
I hope there's still some discount chocolate at the store
though.
Consider this chocolate buds.
Thank you!
I hope there's still some at the store.
No chocolates from Steiner?
No, I think that guy hates me.
No, I'm just kidding.
He gave me some Metal Gear cards.
He was just like, I found these in my collection.
Some like Metal Gear trading cards.
I gave that guy chocolate.
Because I gave stuff to...
I brought like a...
I brought like this pack.
of they said they were like mini cupcakes ashes thank you
chocolates of appreciation thank you it's not white they
know I brought some chocolates for the staff of for the
ocean spark staff and they advertised as like a mini as a
mini chocolate cupcake and oh my gosh failed thank you
unfortunately i've been ill with the flu since thursday no
but getting to watch the show live and bub was such a treat
you and the band and the guests were amazing the crowd were
amazing too also that dress oh my thank you flew in for the
concert but my plane doesn't leave until midnight on
saturday so i have to endorse it you go for the cup oh
kamachan you should have hung out with everybody too that's
okay we all endure um but yeah i brought the ochi spark
there were like they were like little cupcakes and they
advertised them as mini cupcakes but when i say mini
cupcakes they were like the size of a thumbnail the box was
so deceivingly large i was like i opened them up and was
like
I was like, wait, I swear, I'm not trying to, actually, they
were expensive.
I tried to get, like, fancy chocolates for everybody.
I was like, this, I swear I'm not cheaping out on you guys.
Nice of Steiner to let you sing at his live Yu-Gi-Oh card
pack opening.
That guy has all of the, what is it?
all of this this is going to his head he would come back to
me and he would be like like while I was waiting backstage
he would come he would come over and he would be like back
in the day people used to ask me for my autograph you know
you're not so special I was like I don't care old man get
what the times
You guys can't praise him so much Because it literally goes
to his head So please understand You must bully the manager
You must bully the manager It's very very important He must
know his place Back in my day
The future is now old man
We're way ahead of you on that good I got a photo with
Steiner at the show I feel blessed Don't say that It's
cursed He probably has a blockbuster card still Did they
have a blockbuster or in the UK
Can't even take you Thank you, thank you.
You're amazing, Minky.
Thank you.
I'm really not.
I'm not.
Oh my gosh!
I forgot to say something so important!
My!
Flower stand!
My flower stand!
My first ever!
My first ever flower stand!
It was so pretty!
It was so...
I got to take home the...
All the stuff.
Like the little...
I got to take... I took home everything.
I took home the little Ibu's on top.
I took home the big pieces.
I have everybody's names.
And...
I took off everything.
My first ever flower stamp.
So happy.
It looks so beautiful.
So glad you liked it.
Glad you liked it.
Sorry, I'm going to take you.
I'm a random doctor from a far-off country, and it's my
birthday, I!
Happy birthday, 16th doctor!
I'll watch your concert later, hoping the best is ever.
Thank you so much, and happy, happy, happy birthday.
Yeah, I was so...
Oh my gosh, thank you, everybody.
Thank you!
I was so happy.
Since you didn't give us chocolate, can we lick the one
dripping down your legs?
Yeah, you can lick the one in the curtains over there in the
back.
The one on my legs is not edible.
It's decoration.
You know what else looks so beautiful?
Mint in the red dress!
Thank you!
I got chocolate on Valentine's Day for helping move
furniture!
It was a Tony's Choco Lonely Bar.
What's a lonely bar?
What is
that love?
Oh, thank you!
Thanks for making my world a better place than me or
everyone who got to see the show live!
New name, by the way.
YouTube said I had to change it.
Might change again.
Why YouTube said you have to change your name?
It's just a brand of chocolate.
Huh.
Lonely is so good.
Wait, I'm gonna look it up.
The name sounds familiar.
Lonely is Chocolate Lonely.
Oh!
I have had this before.
These are good.
These are yummy.
Wait, if somebody give me these!
This is like, this is like the adult version of getting a
full-size candy bar when you go trick-or-treating as a kid.
That's how excited I get when I...
You know, this is...
These are good.
Congratulations on such a great concert, Vito.
Sorry I missed it.
Oh, it's so good.
Definitely gonna join the pod while I stowed in.
Stay warm!
They're really good if you've never tried these.
Chocolon.
Wait, you got paid nice.
These are tasty.
Toasty, tasty.
What if somebody gave you a Costco mint shake?
I feel like I have to go to Costco now to try it.
I'm shocked.
I'm shocked that they added that to the menu.
I want to try it, though.
Chocolate mint shake at Costco.
I just got it.
It's pretty good, really.
It does taste good.
They just smirked giving it.
Oh, they smirked while giving...
Hello, Minto.
Chocolate mint is everywhere recently.
I just can't get out of your brains.
My branding is so powerful.
It was also like 700 calories.
Mint.
Wherever I go, I see your face.
Binto, you're on my mind 24-7.
Still me.
Samoy!
Thank you for taking the photo.
Oops, no, sorry, I hit my mic.
The photos!
It's wild how fast those photos spread in Discord before I
even upload them to Flickr.
I need to hire you as like official photographer
your photos are so great
just like you with Fubuki oh yeah that did you guys see that
my tweet about the Fubuki house I kept looking at it every
day I would be like Fubuki Sama look over me please look
over me please actually I think on Friday even I was like
Fubuki please bless my show please
It looked so much like her.
Had real Fubuzella in your backyard.
I know.
So great to hear how happy you are about this.
We're so proud of you, Minky.
Thank you.
You know, obviously, I'm very ultra critical.
Oh, see, thank you.
Yeah, understate how proud of you I am.
for your incredible performance but also for what this show
means for making your dreams come true and spreading me to
be pleased thank you thank you sd look at that thank you
thank you for one of the best nights of my life i'm so happy
for you i was worried that you know it's not like your
typical show you know i was like maybe if my set list is too
traditionally jazzy people would be like, oh, this is
boring.
You know, I don't think that, because I love jazz, but I
hope that you've been well.
Thank you.
I am.
I'm so relieved that it's over.
Wait, I mean overstate.
No, I understand what you meant.
It's okay.
Do we know when the original song comes out?
Right now it might be a bit because I am so busy.
I don't think I'll have time to record before I leave for
Japan, so I watched online.
It was great.
Thank you.
Hi.
I just promised I held a watch party.
Everyone in attendance was very impressed that Orison kicked
ass.
We made red bell.
helmet cake to celebrate.
Wait, that's awesome!
Skeletop, I hope you had a great birthday party.
That's okay, I was just asking Song was a killer.
No!
Thank you for asking.
Hmm.
Can you record it in Japan?
Maybe.
Hmm.
How long did you practice with the musicians for the show?
One hour.
It was like maybe like an hour and a half.
Definitely the rehearsal time got cut a bit because of some
tech issues.
It's great to see you again on my birthday!
Hey, I'm still happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Welcome to the cafe jazz edit needs to happen that would be
really awesome I really like the jazz version so great Daryl
did an amazing job at doing the redition
musicians seem like they had the instrumentals down pat well
they were given the set list
maybe I don't remember maybe two months in advance I believe
So that You know I'm sure some of the songs They're very
classic jazz songs So they would know those But Especially
for like some of the other songs Like Sneakier And Can't say
goodbye to yesterday And of course my original songs So Yeah
yeah yeah Yeah
burning question why are they called the la diamond trio if
there are four of them i don't know don't ask of me i don't
know don't ask of me
that's that's outside of my knowledge
maybe it's like pinky and the brain and larry version of
snake eater was amazing i i felt so i seriously i just can't
stop being like wow i got to sing snake eater with a live
band wow wow
the important questions why is your name in phantom if you
are turquoise
Terry can't say goodbye to yesterday.
A bunch of us were IRL pogging and jumping at the trumpet
player waiting for the five-minute sax solo to start.
You know, actually, the version that they sent me for can't
say goodbye to yesterday was much short, was shortened like
crazy.
So they ended up going for the full version, which I think
was really, really awesome.
so that was that was them yeah they went ham all on their
own i think that they maybe enjoyed it so they uh like it
was a little shorter ish but yeah it wasn't it was uh the
version that i was practicing off of was even shorter than
that so it did good me thank you
So happy, so happy.
Now I can say that I've performed with a live jazz band.
I'm a jazz singer, baby.
Though, I'm like, you know, I'm like singing seriously,
right?
But for all my MCs, I'm like, I'm like, Okie dokie, guys!
Are you ready for the next song?
I couldn't set the mood in the place at all I was I was like
Hey guys It's time for the next song
Instead of being like Hey all you cool cats there out in the
crowd Here's a special one for you For you and your special
someone No instead I'm like Guys Guys I'm nervous
I couldn't stop saying Okido You are so beautiful in the red
dress.
Thank you.
It's so strange.
Oh man, having my hair fully down.
It feels so strange.
I'm being all dressed up.
Weird.
I wouldn't have you any other way.
I don't think I could change.
In the free VOD preview, you actually say okie dokie.
Don't tell me that!
Okay, I have time to nuke the VOD.
I would have died if he did do that.
What?
Try to be like a cool professional.
Not only are you a jazz singer, you're a professional jazz
singer that sold out the house twice!
Oh, you're right.
Okie dokie.
No!
All that Okie dokie was just the Fallout brain rot.
Is that a thing in Fallout?
I was talking to some of the...
Oh, she sparked staff before the show.
No.
Yes, before the show.
And I was like, you know, I've never played Fallout before.
But some of the songs that I have in my set list are really
popular because of Fallout.
The MC says a lot.
Oh my gosh, it's so funny.
And, um...
And they were like, oh, I didn't know, I didn't know.
Oh, I would like to play it someday because, you know, of...
I feel like the aesthetic is really cool.
But, um, afterwards, after the first show, I was, like,
scrolling through the hashtag.
And I saw...
Surprisingly, I saw some, like, Japanese viewers watching,
and I was so surprised.
So I was really happy.
But there was one that was in Japanese that was, like...
Oh, yeah.
the song she's saying it's from fallout and i was like i was
like even in japan even in japan it is not some chips thank
you gee minto what do you want to do tonight the same thing
we do every night wishby try to take over the world it's
minto and i boo it's minto and i boo
JP loves the fallout show, do they?
Concert, congrats, miito, thank you!
Wow.
Yeah, fallout, yeah, definitely, you know, obviously the
songs were popular in their own way as well, but, like, into
kind of like a mainstream.
Into the gamer, into the gamer media.
Fallout taught several generations about jazz.
did that don't you forget it oh my gosh MGS4 announcement I
feel so I I listened back to when I was on Doki stream first
of all I want to say I'm so sorry I couldn't do my own watch
along I so what had happened was is I installed everything
on my computer.
My travel setup computer, I mean.
Arigato, Arigato, too.
Kamo, thank you.
It was a great way to spend my birthday weekend.
I wouldn't have had any other way.
Thank you.
Happy birthday.
Digital Canary, thank you.
So proud of you.
You were great and beautiful.
You're saying it was amazing.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Um.
Yes, so I had installed everything on my travel computer and
then I It was Windows 11 and I Pushed it back to Windows 10
And after I did that I completely Spaced I was like I forgot
to reinstall everything I was like Oh my gosh I'm such a
dummy Dumbhead I was like no I forgot to.
And I, like there were a bunch of drivers things that were
not working.
And I, like, I had a Bluetooth keyboard that I didn't
reconnect.
And it was just, it was a mess.
I was like, oh my gosh.
And the Bluetooth keyboard that I brought with me was not
corded.
So I, it was, it was all or nothing.
It was, and so I was like, oh my gosh.
um so i really apologize about that that was all on me i
even made like the the waiting room and everything i was
like i'm prepared to do this watch along uh except i was and
so i went on doki stream to watch it and it was super duper
scuffed on my end uh i had to watch i had to like use my I
was like on speakerphone on my phone, right?
At least this wasn't the Japan trip.
I know, I know.
The Watch Along with Doki was very funny, though.
I was watching a clip.
I didn't know how bad I was cutting out.
It literally was going like, little, middle gear, little.
Because it's funny because I was like, I was throwing myself
on the bed.
around i was screaming and uh also my my stream would not
sink for some reason and then i also my stream stopped
working when metal gear got announced i gotta get you to try
linux linux mint yeah yeah don't feel bad it was really
entertaining all the same it was so it was so funny I can't
believe the timing.
Patrons, shut her down.
Had a great time.
I want to take your chance to show you and everyone else
involved.
It's great.
Thank you for working so hard for us.
You make us all proud to call us yourselves.
I will make me proud to call you by Kamioshi.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm simply...
I chose to believe the Discord call simply cannot contain
excitement that's yes i think i think it was it was so funny
i didn't realize how bad it was though
oh but oh my gosh metal gear and metal gear and i need the
love pack t-shirt actually i hope they make that.
I want to buy that.
Konami, please.
Konami.
This is a desperate plea from me.
Please make official love pack t-shirts.
I will purchase.
Please.
Konami make official love pack t-shirts.
I would love pack to have one.
Thank you.
They said okay.
Yippee!
Been binging MGS this year.
Ready for four!
Oh my gosh, this is going to be so many people's first time
playing MGS4.
I'm so...
Oh gosh.
I'm so happy.
I am surprised that portable ops is not in the collection.
I did see some people.
Mito, oh, heyo!
Oh, heyo!
I did say, I did see some people saying, like, they hoped
for Ashton as well.
And I saw people saying they hoped for...
I saw someone saying, like...
Um...
They were like, I want to see Metal Gear rising on modern
day consoles and I'm like but it's on Steam it's it's on
Steam but I imagine that probably MGS4 takes up so much
space probably but yeah it goes Vival
so many people's first time with Peace Walk on yeah
I mean I get that PC is not a console but it's so easy to
get the steam deck is a
console steam version doesn't have DLC what's the DLC what
the did they have DLC for you see snake is coming to rainbow
rainbow six siege I did I've been tagged by at least 500
people.
Actually, Doki sent me a thing right before stream.
She was like, are you going to play Rainbow Six Siege?
And I was like, no.
No.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, chat.
I'm new here.
Does Mint not like Death Stranding or does she just like Big
Boss so much?
Hi, welcome.
I do like Death Stranding.
I just haven't beat it yet.
And and I do love Big Boss.
I just love Metal Gear.
Actually, I love Metal Gear in general.
Not just Big Boss.
I love all the Metal Gear.
But yeah, I'm afraid of playing Rainbow Six Siege.
So I'm afraid of being called very colorful names.
And also, I'm scared of everything.
I'm scared.
Green.
Yeah, they're gonna call me green.
Just got back from dinner.
Ooh, yummy!
Did you see Sam Fisher and Solid Sankey?
Solid Sankey!
What if you both were bad at Rainbow Six Siege together and
you got to play Snake?
Look.
You know, I have the Snake skin on...
Fortnite?
Snake and Fortnite did not give me to play Fortnite.
I don't think Snake and Rainbow Six Siege will give me to
play.
I mean, I love that they added him.
Don't get me wrong.
Love the concert.
Me and my tape here are right next to the table throwing
room.
The roses on stage were so sweet.
Thank you guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Rising is actually region locked.
Oh, I think it's region locked.
Or rather, I don't think it's region locked anymore, but
there was a while.
It was for a while, I believe Japan couldn't have it, no?
This bio in game has a description from AutoCAD.
Wait, that's so cute!
I can't believe it.
how well the Ibu were dressed for the show.
It was so cute!
It was so so so cute.
Yay!
I also saw some people wishing that Twin Snakes were on were
in the Master Collection.
But I think we'll probably I would, I hope we see that in
the GameCube uh collection for the Switch, you know?
Um...
YouTube is down worldwide.
Oh.
Oh no!
Wait, what's that have to do with me?
I think, uh...
I think with the Twin Snakes, there's a couple...
couple things with it, right?
Because it was...
You know, say... I think it's like tied up in legal stuff
with What's it called, Silicon Knights?
They don't exist anymore.
And then...
And then also, if it's like a Nintendo thing, like they
couldn't just put the game on only the Master Collection
that's released for the Switch, you know?
So...
I hope that we get it for the GameCube Collection on the
Switch instead.
It's like that Tetris stream from 2020 all over again.
Oh my gosh.
you're right!
It is.
Yeah, licensing and stuff.
Silicon Knights, eternal darkness.
I hope, though.
I hope, I hope, I hope.
If they can add Sora and Smash, they could get Twin Snakes.
We'll see.
Maybe in the future.
I think it would be fun to have it.
Yeah.
Hopefully in the future.
Some of the RE6, oh not RE6, R6 characters are getting
Merrill, Psycho Mantis, and Grey Fox skins as well.
What?
The rainbow, that's Rainbow Six, right?
Yeah.
Going to get the new Naked Snake Nendo.
He can go on a date with Koharu.
Wait.
If I ever get a Nendoroid one day, then I can be next to
Snake and Koharu.
and Ryden ooh, Ryden
wait, I want an Enderoy now I want an Enderoy I didn't think
about that
I could be next to both of them
it wasn't in production already I think you guys I love that
you guys give me so much credit but I didn't get only
recently Did like a crazy ton of offers for things Come
through But I don't actually get so many like Uh Like only
until recently But before then I Uh do not have so many
offers for things Hmm
So Yeah You know I love that you guys think that I could and
think that things are in production like that I'm not just
like keeping it a secret I mean obviously I would but you
know since nothing is in production right now since nothing
is in production right now
but hopefully one day hopefully one day hopefully one day
but not to say that you know I don't have some things lined
up actually there's one thing that i it's not how do i
describe it i to me it's like a big deal but in actuality
it's not a big thing but that will be announced in two weeks
yeah ish yeah
for me it's cool bragging rights and also it was one of the
most terrifying experiences of my afterlife that i will be
able to tell you guys once about it
maybe it could be maybe bragging rights for you guys too a
little bit
spooky yeah spooky excited for everything you have to offer
us minto i'm trying i do try but at the same time i'm like
man you know it would be so cool to get like an android and
things like that but but also i fear your wallets so so at
the same time we we try to take it easy i had to be like to
steiner i had to be like um i'm can we like not do so much
merch because i'm nervous about everybody
So I would like to say once again, if you cannot afford a
merch, or if you cannot afford to go to an event, or
something like that, I know, especially events suck because
of FOMO and everything, but please do not, do not, do not,
do not go into bed.
Thank you so much for the redirect.
Thank you, thank you!
Everyone's talking about the YouTube main page.
Is it really down?
Oh wow, it really is.
I go to it and I see nothing.
Wow.
Wait, how am I gonna watch my deer cam?
Good thing I know what it's called.
We're locked in with Minto.
I was thinking of going soon.
I know it's a little bit of a shorter stream.
I apologize.
Because...
My voice...
Tomorrow I have no stream.
I was like, I'm gonna rest my voice.
But you know what I have to do?
I have to record more Portal 2.
I support Minto even at 26.99 APY.
No!
As long as you don't make a Funko, Minky.
I was approached not by Funko, but I was approached by
another company of a similar sword.
I did say no.
I did turn that down.
Because I...
Didn't want to.
So...
Why did my tongue come out?
Uh...
Yes.
Bam.
Yes, yes.
Uh...
Wonderful concert!
Your sound lovely is okay if I miss the Toronto meet and
greet since I see Yoko Kano the next weekend.
Of course, Nicholas.
Though I will miss you.
I feel like I haven't seen that at a meet and greet in a
while.
no no no i did not get an offer for funko pop i did not i
did not is what i was saying but there was another company
that makes similar uh figures and such that i said no to so
i love yoshi
but i will not say
La booboo?
Isn't it crazy how La booboos are like totally out of style
now?
Is that so crazy?
Like you don't see people using them at all anymore.
They lasted a while though.
I still liked how La booboos looked.
I still thought they were cute.
But I didn't get one in the end.
Fads be fighting.
Yeah, they do.
Labu, labu, labu.
I always said, do you need more Minto merch?
Excited for your new plans.
Thank you!
Fugglers?
I like Fugglers.
I like, I like ugly cute things though.
Minky Outlast and Laboobus.
Yippee!
But I'm dead.
I, I, no.
I persevered!
Oh.
Fugglers have more soul.
My YouTube feed is down, but Minky is up and working.
Ah, crazy.
Feed is...
I wonder what's going on with YouTube.
Really is down.
Wait, can I...
Oh!
I can't even get to, like, my channel.
I need a Minto Bionicle.
Oh.
I will...
If I...
Hopefully one day...
I would really love, like...
It doesn't have to be a scale figure.
But like, you know, even like a pop-up parade.
I would be really excited about...
I would be really excited about that.
If I could get...
That would be a goal of mine.
One to one scale.
One to one scale figure.
One seventh scale.
one-sixth one-fourth bunny me yeah yeah what is that brand
that does all the one-fourth uh one-fourth uh what is what
is what is what is freeing yes freeing I was like their name
is like that anime the swimming anime meinto cubics merch
what is Cubics.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'll ask Steiner Manet if it's possible.
I'll ask if it's possible.
Never say it's impossible.
Minto Companion Cube?
No way.
Wait.
Minto Half-Life 3.
Minto in Half-Life 3.
Or in Portal 3.
Companion Cube.
Please, Gabin.
Welcome back, Frosted Channel.
Thank you.
I almost don't want to leave because...
Because YouTube is down, I feel like I'm rare.
That I'm streaming.
I'm like, ugh.
I'm the chosen one.
It's my birthday tomorrow if you have a good time off.
And or playing Portal.
Jeez!
I'm sorry!
Happy birthday!
It's funny because if I stream, or not stream, if I record
portal tomorrow, you will know.
What if I streamed it without looking at chat at all?
Like it was like a normal playthrough and then I private the
bot and then when I go to upload it.
I would just do it like how I have been doing.
It would just be a little preview of the portal playthrough.
And I wouldn't be looking at chat at all because there would
be no chat.
Could you resist looking at chat?
I would literally minimize it.
Backseaters will mauldhard.
There's only been a few puzzles that I've been stuck on.
I can't quite remember where I'm at now, though.
But I...
I am on chapter...
I'm either on chapter 6 or...
I
think I am on chapter 7.
I won't say it.
I won't give you the satisfaction.
It's actually kind of funny when it comes up naturally you
honestly Don't realize it's such a the two numbers are such
a good like guesstimator you don't realize how often you
actually say it You know what I mean?
Like it's kind of insane How how often
that those two numbers became such a meme are like so funny.
Say it.
Mr. Mick, Flap, look at it.
Don't.
Don't eat that amount.
Don't go to the dark side.
I've only realized it now that I've been trying to avoid it.
I know, me too.
Ugh.
the painful realization.
Yes, YouTube is down, everybody.
YouTube is down.
But you are safe here.
You are safe in my little channel.
Actually, I think I'm gonna go though.
I wonder...
There was a place I wanted to see if I could go to.
What the heck?
I cannot believe my VOD preview got... It cannot be
monetized.
It can't be monetized!
I was too good.
Sounding like the original.
Oh my god.
It's alright.
Hold on one second.
It's okay.
They usually don't get monetized anyway.
See like roses?
My crew brought bouquet and grateful to the venue to see
this next to the stage.
Tossing Rose for Can't Say Goodbye.
fine.
Snake eater was such a thrill.
Thanks for a great show.
I love the roses!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I love them.
Thank you so much.
I feel like we need a Walter White clip where his face is
replaced with a 6 and 7 and he says, say my name.
Sound like that jazz singer and mint phantom.
Walter.
Say my name.
You're damn right are you gonna upload a full video of the
concert that is a great question um right now because
there's the streaming tickets up uh not at the moment um
perhaps in you know i haven't discussed this with literally
anybody um but perhaps in maybe a long long long long time
from now maybe in like a year or so because obviously that
would not be fair for the people who are purchasing the
streaming tickets and everything but I would for my own sake
I would really love it to be archived somewhere so everyone
killed it on stage my only regret was not being there in
person but it was life after life changing regardless I'm
telling all my normie friends how awesome it was.
Hope you like the Roku Nana name and the flower stand.
I don't think I...
Wait, what?
Was that you?
I don't think I should...
I googled whether YouTube was down only to hear Minto
confirm my suspicions.
Yep.
It's so funny how, like, when YouTube goes down,
literally...
If...
When YouTube goes down...
uh everybody like starts freaking out they're coming into my
chat being like youtube down for your eyes my youtube shorts
how am i supposed to watch the next part of of of hell's
kitchen that has been released in seven shorts youtube
shorts goodness gracious um I would like to ask, though, you
know, I know that I can't stop people from uploading the
full version of the concert, but I would love to ask that
you do not so that I could do it myself.
Eventually.
So, I hope that people will respect that so that we can keep
doing more streams and such and such of things like this in
the future so pet girls thank you i'm late hi me though
thank you you're not late at all it was wonderful hearing
you sing snake eater live and meeting other eyeballs okay
forward to the next one thank you so much thank you
tasty viewing statistics from me though exactly thank you
well guys i think i will head off now actually so i can i
know sorry that it wasn't a very long stream after just
coming back from a couple days gone i'm really sorry that i
couldn't do the mod preview on valentines like i anticipated
because of the I know they wanted to polish it and stuff
which seems like they did so yeah
I hope you guys had a great weekend and everything
yeah I really thank you so much for all the support with the
concert I know that some people sometimes get sad that like
you know outside events try sometimes hinder my streaming
schedule um and you know i am sorry about that but i hope
that you understand that things like these are a dream come
true to me so um i you know i try to do my best to balance
as much streaming as i can with events as well and it's uh
you know doing my best yeah thank you for the magical
experience this past weekend thank you thank you no thank
you you guys make everything that i do so magical so um yeah
and you know if you can't go to stuff in person uh we do try
our best to also have a streaming option available as well
so i'll keep i'll keep trying for those opportunities as
well for future stuff too.
Yes.
Yes, yes.
And also, you know, these types of events also make it so
that I am able to stream more in a sense because yeah, it's
just, you know.
I feel refreshed.
Even though I don't sound refreshed, with my voice, I feel
refreshed, so
But yes, thank you so much, everybody Thank you, thank you,
thank you, hopefully You know what I might actually do
tomorrow As like a member stream or something A little
behind the scenes Portal 2 Where I don't look at chat It
will be random When I stream it But of course the VOD will,
or the Part will be uploaded to
to YouTube as a video itself.
Yeah.
I will thank you!
I couldn't put my part to the flower stand because I
completely forgot.
But you deserve that.
It is so much more.
Don't be afraid of dreaming bigger.
We will fill a stadium for you.
No!
Thank you, no!
That's nice hearing you talk about the concert, other
things.
Thank you, Tiyaki.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, it's Omito everybody!
Otomi, Otomi, otomi, otomi, otomi, otomi, otomi, otomi!
Etero-t-hi, have a good day, have a good time, y'all.
And I will see you when I see you next!
Etero-ttero-hi!
Oh gosh, I sound so bad, sorry.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye!
Why was it all?
On!
How is it on?